[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute
schönen guten abend mit mir im studio
ist kristin otto für den sport ja hallo
und guten abend
international ist und bleibt die
politische großwetterlage angespannt wie
selten hier sind unsere themen
brisanter besuch die vorsitzende des us
repräsentantenhauses nancy pelosi ist in
taiwan china reagiert mit schafen
drohungen
schlag gegen den terror die usa töteten
al-kaida-chef al sawahiri bei einem
drohnenangriff
und erfolgreiches comeback in
deutschland mario götze erreicht mit der
frankfurter eintracht die zweite runde
im dfb-pokal eine
[Musik]
weitere ernsthafte krise braut sich
zusammen trotz aller schärfster
warnungen aus china ist nancy pelosi vor
zirka zwei stunden in taiwan gelandet
die sprecherin des us
repräsentantenhauses
befindet sich derzeit auf asienreise ihr
umstrittener abstecher in die
taiwanesischen hauptstadt taipeh
verschärft die us-chinesischen
beziehungen aufs äußerste mit welchen
folgen dazu gleich live unsere
korrespondenten in china und den usa zum
hintergrund des konfliktes kurz volker
dutschek geht es nach peking gehört
taiwan zur kommunistischen volksrepublik
china taiwan bezeichnet sich dagegen als
republik china und wird seit den 90er
jahren demokratisch regiert
regierungssitz taipeh
außenpolitisch vertritt peking die ein
china doktrin das heißt der
diplomatische beziehungen mit china
haben will kann nicht mit taipeh reden
sondern nur mit peking auch die usa
haben keine diplomatischen beziehungen
zu taiwan was sie aber nicht daran
hindert waffen in die inselrepublik zu
liefern die usa sind der wichtigste
verbündete taiwans
china strebt jedenfalls eine
wiedervereinigung mit taiwan an notfalls
auch militärisch woraufhin us-präsident
beiden noch im mai erklärte die usa
seien für diesen fall bereit taiwan zur
seite zu stehen kloses besuch jetzt ist
der ranghöchste der us-politik seit 25
jahren und laut chinesischem
außenministerium ein spiel mit dem feuer
ulf röller berichtet
die ersten bilder von nancy pelosi
ankunft in taiwans hauptstadt taipeh ein
umstrittener ein gefährlicher besuch der
die beiden weltmächte china amerika in
einen konflikt treibt wie gefährlich
diese reise ist zeigen diese
veröffentlichten videos des chinesischen
verteidigungsministeriums
die armee probe für den ernstfall auch
für eine invasion taiwans eine warnung
an die usa
ein solcher besuch ist offensichtlich
sehr gefährlich er untergräbt den
frieden und die stabilität in der region
die antwort der chinesen ließ nicht
lange auf sich warten das
verteidigungsministerium kündigt eine
viertägige militärübung an in der taiwan
umzingelt wird
die taiwanesen bereiten sich schon seit
längerem auf das schlimmste vor
probealarm in der hauptstadt die
menschen üben den notfall eines angriffs
der chinesen es herrscht ein gefühl in
der stadt zwischen hoffen und bangen
ich glaube bei einem konflikt stehen die
usa auf unserer seite
der besuch kommt zu einer heiklen zeit
egal wie man sich verhält es gibt kein
richtig oder falsch
vor der küste taiwans belauern sich die
usa und china für pekings machthaber ist
die insel ein teil der volksrepublik die
usa haben ihren flugzeugträger uss
ronald reagan in die region geschickt
sie empfinden sich als schutzmacht
taiwans es ist ein duell der weltmächte
sollten china eine krise anzetteln oder
die situation eskalieren lassen
dann ist peking daran schuld wir
erwarten von ihnen sich
verantwortungsvoll zu verhalten
taiwan hofft auf amerikas helfe das land
heißt die vorsitzende polos sie
willkommen ein herzlicher empfang für
einen besuch der eine ganze region in
die krise stürzen kann
es ist eine brenzlige situation über die
wir jetzt mit unserem korrespondenten in
washington und peking sprechen zunächst
zu ulf röller ulf es ist ein spiel mit
dem feuer hat peking direkt nach der
landung gesagt wird dass china bei
scharfer rhetorik belassen
nein sondern sie wird auch bei anders
werden sie wird nicht nur scharf sein
die rhetorik sondern es wird auch
geschossen im wasser des wortes china
hat sofort nach der ankunft von nancy
pelosi angekündigt dass sie mehrere
militärübungen in der region durchführen
werden die erste sofort wenn pelosi
weggeflogen ist wieder und das ist eine
massive militärübung in der man quasi
taiwan umzingelt mit dem chinesisch
militär dann sollen noch weitere folgen
also man sieht dass fast shipping
angedroht hat macht er war er nimmt
diesen versuch sehr sehr persönlich man
weiß dass quasi die historische mission
von shipping ist die wiedervereinigung
oder die vereinigung mit taiwan und
durch diesen besuch von frau pelosi
glaubt sie dass amerika die
eigenständigkeit von taiwan theben
erhalten will und damit sich an
absprachen nicht hält die man mit china
getroffen hat insofern reagiert er jetzt
sehr sehr hart und dies wird die region
über monate wahrscheinlich über jahre
wirklich beschäftigen
weiter zu el mati wissen immer was tut
das weiße haus jetzt damit die lage
nicht weiter eskaliert
also das weiße haus versucht zweierlei
einerseits herunterzuspielen die
bedeutung dieses besuchs habe ja in den
letzten wochen so heißt es eben auch
tatsächlich delegationen des kongresses
gegeben politiker aus den usa vielleicht
nicht ganz so hochrangig also das sei
eigentlich nichts besonderes und vor
allen dingen würde das auch keine
verletzung sein der ein china politik
die eben klar macht dass peking der
hauptansprechpartner ist zum zweiten
versuch das weiße haus auch klar zu
machen dass beide seiten zu viel zu
verlieren haben wenn es zu einer
eskalation kommt man findet hinter den
kulissen hier diesen besuch unklug von
der sprecherin des repräsentantenhauses
weil china da tatsächlich möglicherweise
eine art zweite front werden könnte
während man ja gerade mit dem ukraine
krieg beschäftigt ist china enger mit
russland zusammen rückt auch
wirtschaftlich hätte dass große
nachteile für beide seiten in dieser
region wenn es zum konflikt käme und am
ende wollte man ja viele dinge zusammen
machen beispielsweise im kampf gegen den
klimawandel über zwei stunden hat
präsident beiden ja letzte woche mit
jean ping gesprochen also man weiß hier
daraufhin beide seiten haben zu viel zu
verlieren macht demonstrationen in den
nächsten tagen wird man hier akzeptieren
aber eine militärische eskalation würde
man auch aus washington entsprechend
beantworten eine potenziell gefährliche
situation danke für die einschätzung
nach washington peking ulf röller und
elmar theveßen wenn sie noch fragen zum
konflikt um taiwan haben die können sie
stellen bei uns zdf heute live um 19 30
auf unseren social media kanälen und in
der app und dort finden sie dann auch
weitere informationen kompakt
zusammengefasst beispielsweise zur
militärischen und wirtschaftlichen
bedeutung times
er war einer der meistgesuchten
terroristen der welt al kaida chef aiman
al zawahiri jetzt haben die usa in bei
einem drohnenangriff in afghanistan
getötet jahrelang war al sawahiri nummer
zwei hinter osama bin laden plante unter
anderem die anschläge vom 11 september
2001 sein spitzname als gelernter arzt
terror doktor 25 millionen dollar
kopfgeld hatte washington auf ihn
ausgesetzt mehr von claudia bates
rauch über einem haus in kabul laut us
geheimdienst hatte der chef der
terror-organisation al-qaida in der
afghanischen hauptstadt bei seiner
familie unterschlupf gefunden der
drohnenangriff habe als er war hier auf
einem balkon getroffen und sei seit
sechs monaten geplant worden
der gerechtigkeit wurde genüge getan
diesen terroristenführer gibt es nicht
mehr die menschheit muss diesen
teuflischen mörder nicht mehr fürchten
ayman al zawahiri war über jahrzehnte
zunächst der mann hinter osama bin laden
der chefstratege von al qaida der
architekt der anschläge vom 11 september
2001 und vieler weiterer anschläge auf
die usa und ihre verbündeten nach dem
chaotischen abzug der us-truppen aus
afghanistan hatte präsident biden gegen
kritik beteuert die usa könnten den
anti-terror-kampf aus der ferne
fortsetzen und sieht sich bestätigt
ganz gleich wie lange es dauert und wo
ihr euch versteckt wenn ihr unser volk
bedroht werden wir euch finden und außer
gefecht setzen
nach us erkenntnissen gehörte das haus
in dem al sawahiri sich aufhielt einem
engen mitarbeiter des afghanischen
innenministers hakkani selbst chef eines
terrornetzwerks
die taliban haben ihre lektion nicht
gelernt
es zeigt dass die al kaida führung der
zirkel um al zawahiri
weiterhin eine enge beziehung hat zur
führung der taliban
vor dem us abzug hatten die taliban
zugesagt mit al qaida zu brechen die usa
sehen dieses abkommen nun verletzt
jetzt in die ukraine das oft regiment
einen kampfverband der vor allem durch
wochenlanges verteidigen der stadt
mariupol bekannt wurde jetzt hat das
oberste gericht russlands das regiment
als terroristische organisation
eingestuft viele soldaten sind in
russischer gefangenschaft nachdem sie
das stahlwerk aufgegeben hatten und
verlassen mussten durch die einstufung
als terror-organisation können
mitglieder des as of regiments mit
langen haftstrafen belegt werden bis zu
20 jahren
immer mehr verbrauchern flattert in
diesen tagen eine preiserhöhung beim gas
ins aus aktuelles beispiel beim kölner
energieversorger rheinenergie werden ab
oktober
133 prozent mehr fällig angesichts
dieser entwicklung wird jetzt
tatsächlich auch wieder über heimische
gasvorkommen diskutiert davon ist ein
großteil allerdings nur mit einer
umstrittenen methode erreichbar nämlich
die fracking und dabei wird unter hohem
druck ein gemisch aus wasser aus sand
und chemikalien in tiefe
gesteinsschichten gepresst und durch die
entstehenden risse kann das gas
entweichen und gefördert werden über die
chancen und risiken oliver deuker 5
prozent des deutschen erdgasbedarfs
werden noch hierzulande gefördert man
unterscheidet zwischen konventionellem
und unkonventionellem gas letzteres
schlummert in sehr engem bogen
schiefergestein und kann nur mit der
umstrittenen und in deutschland
verbotenen fracking methode gefördert
werden die industrie steht bereit sollte
die politik das verbot kippen und
parallel dazu die mobilisierung der
notwendigen technologie auch erfolg ist
durch die industrie dann ist man in der
lage innerhalb von einigen monaten als
erste schiefer gas zu fördern sagen wir
ein halbes jahr an konventionellem
erdgas wurden im vergangenen jahr 5,2
milliarden kubikmeter gefördert etwa
32,4 milliarden kubikmeter schlummern
noch im boden die bestände an
unkonventionellem gas wie schiefergas
deutlich größer bis zu 22.000 600
milliarden kubikmeter davon seien 2300
milliarden kubikmeter technisch
förderbar umweltschützer sind aber klar
dagegen dürfen wir einfach keine
sinnvolle lösung um unsere emissionen zu
reduzieren und gleichzeitig werden dort
dann investition getätigt die ein den
die lehre führen und diese investition
die brauchen wir eigentlich für die
erneuerbaren oder für energieeinsparung
außerdem sei fracking alles andere als
umweltfreundlich kritisieren
energiewissenschaftler die probleme sind
erst mal dass man chemiekalien mit dem
boden rein fressen muss aber der größere
schaden ist dass man mit wahnsinnigen
druck in den untergrund gehen muss um
das gestein aufzubrechen und damit
bricht man natürlich struktur auf und
findet immer kontrolliert aufgebrochen
eine folge könnten kleine erdbeben sein
die es schon mehrfach in gas
fördergebieten gab ob in deutschland
wieder gefragt wird politisch ist das
derzeit schwer durchsetzbar
neue energievorräte erschließen ist in
der krise das eine mittel energiesparen
das andere und deshalb hat spanien jetzt
strenge maßnahmen beschlossen so dürfen
öffentliche gebäude aber auch kaufhäuser
oder flughäfen im sommer nicht auf
weniger als 27 grad runtergekühlt und im
winter auf maximal 19 grad beheizt
werden an beleuchteten bauwerken und in
schaufenstern muss um 22 uhr das licht
ausgehen
wie gefährlich sind die affen pocken und
wie werden sie übertragen die deutsche
krankenhausgesellschaft fordert darüber
besser aufzuklären mittlerweile gibt es
allein in deutschland mehr als 2700
infizierte unter ihnen erstmals auch
zwei jugendliche wie das lka heute
berichtet ein impfstoff ist seit kurzem
in europa zugelassen die niederlande
haben schon eine kampagne gestartet mehr
erfahren wir jetzt von florian a
zwei jahre mussten sie wegen corona
pausieren jetzt läuft die gay pride in
amsterdam wieder an doch während die
eine pandemie noch nicht vorbei ist
bereitet schon die nächste
virusinfektion sorgen
ich bin so glücklich aber jetzt gibt es
nach corona die affen pocken ich bekomme
morgen meine impfung ich habe eine
einladung per brief bekommen übertragen
werden affen pocken von mensch zu mensch
durch engen etwa sexuellen kontakt
möglich auch schmierinfektionen über
oberflächen als unwahrscheinlich
hingegen gilt die übertragung über ihre
sohle kleinste partikel in der luft beim
gesundheitsdienst in amsterdam
beobachten sie dass der ausbruch vor
allem männer betrifft die sex mit
männern haben seit der impfstoff
zugelassen wurde impfen sie hier daher
systematisch die risikogruppen
glück wir laden gezielt männer ein die
prophylaxe gegen hiv-infektionen nehmen
das ist die erste gruppe die zweite
gruppe wo wir den ausbruch häufiger
feststellen sind männer die hiv
infiziert sind die kommen dann an die
reihe kommen dann wird das problem
weltweit fehlt es an impfstoff auch hier
im kalifornischen san francisco wo
menschen stundenlang auf eine impfung
warten oder in deutschland wir haben
jetzt nur eine recht geringe anzahl von
im stoßen zur zeit da kommen noch mal
demnächst 200.000 dazu aber auch das
wird nicht reichen um alle menschen
impfen zu können die jetzt eine impfung
brauchen
in amsterdam nutzen sie nun die
leerstehenden cupid impfzentren
vergangene woche wurden hier 500
menschen gegen affen pocken geimpft
sinti und roma aus ganz europa haben in
der gedenkstätte auschwitz birkenau an
die ermordung von angehörigen durch die
nationalsozialisten erinnert
bundesratspräsident bodo ramelow mahnte
vielerorts würden sie wieder in einer
art unausgesprochene
apartheid an den rand gedrängt seit 2015
ist der zweite august offiziell der
europäische holocaust gedenktag für
sinti und roma
500.000 wurden von den nazis ermordet
ein mutmaßlicher rechts terrorist steht
in frankfurt vor dem oberlandesgericht
marvin ehe muss sich verantworten weil
er anschläge in deutschland geplant
haben soll der 20-jährige aus nordhessen
soll versucht haben einen ableger der
rechts terroristischen gruppierung
atomwaffen division zu gründen und
anhänger zu gewinnen
außerdem ist er wegen verstößen gegen
das waffen- und sprengstoffgesetz
angeklagt
ihr nachname war programm trude unruh
hat sich über jahre engagiert für die
senioren in deutschland wie jetzt
bekannt wurde ist die streitbare
politikerin im alter von 96 jahren
gestorben
seit den 70er jahren war die symbolfigur
des senioren schutzbundes graue panther
ende der 80er sah sie drei jahre lang im
bundestag und kämpfte unter anderem für
eine grundrente und die freie wahl der
altenpflege
13 erstliga vereine haben bisher die
zweite runde im dfb pokal erreicht ganz
souverän jetzt auch eintracht frankfurt
das macht richtig lust auf mehr vier
tage vor dem bundesliga-auftakt gegen
die bayern zeigt sich der europa league
gewinner um neuzugang mario götze
bereits gut in schwung in magdeburg
bejubelte die eintracht einen 14 0 sieg
mit der nummer 27 spielt mario wird
seinen schnellen doppelpass mit philipp
kostet die zweitliga aufsteiger aus
magdeburg sind überrumpelt die gäste aus
frankfurt gehen in führung vierte minute
der kamera nachdem kevin trapp einen
foulelfmeter von magdeburgs andreas
müller gehalten hat kommt götzis
nächster glanz passe der wm torschütze
von 2014 weiß bei seinem eintrag die
bücher genau wie ansgar knauf ins spiel
zu bringen ist torwart dominik reimann
ist zur stelle doch hier ist berlin
strömen kann mit dem ball noch etwas
anfangen 2 0 für frankfurt zur 1000
danach trifft nochmal kammer da präzise
zum 30 und der neunzigsten minute luca
salado nach vorarbeit von kuranyi zum 4
0 am ende der eintrag gala mit mario
götze in einer tragenden rolle
zwei tage nach dem em finale gibt es für
die deutschen fußballerinnen eine
weitere tolle anerkennung die uefa
wählte fünf spielerinnen aus dem team
von martina voss tecklenburg in die
beste elf des turniers
den em titel knapp verpasst aber dennoch
überzeugt gleich fünf deutsche
nationalspielerinnen gehören zur
illustren geehrten 11 gewählt von einem
uefa expertengremium dabei ist natürlich
alexandra popp die deutsche kapitänin
und sechsfach torschützen und auch
verteidigerin julia gewinn sie hat es
nach kreuzbandriss 2020 ins em finale
geschafft und noch eine abwehrspielerin
wurde geehrt die 32 jährige marina
hegering spitzname maschine trotz ihrer
corona infektion und verpasste im
halbfinale und finale wurde auch klara
buhl ins team gewählt letztlich
komplettiert die als jahrhunderttalent
gefeierte erst 20 jährige lena oberdorf
die wertvolle 11
viele zahlen und von den
europameisterinnen aus england sind vier
dabei eine weniger des treffens kleines
dankeschön christi morgen macht sich der
hitze hammer auf den weg mit
höchsttemperaturen über 30 grad
übermorgen wird dann mal wieder ein
vorläufiger hitze höhepunkt erreicht
mehr gleich von katja or never das heute
journal mit christian sievers um 21 uhr
45 von uns schön dank und für sie schön
abend
[Musik]
guten abend ihr jetzt im august werden
die tage schon langsam kürzer und die
nächte wieder länger das macht sich
morgens früh dadurch bemerkbar dass ich
etwas nebel oder dunst hier zum beispiel
an der donau aber auch in den
mittelgebirgen mal ein bisschen halten
kann aber meist nach ein zwei stunden
ist der dunst dann weg und dann gibt es
meist nur kleine harmlose quellwolken
oder mal höhere schleierwolken jetzt
wird es heiss und die hitze kommt das
sieht westeuropa in spanien gab es heute
schon 43 grad mal wieder in
südfrankreich 36 und bei uns 31 grad
kommende nacht können sie nochmal ganz
gut durchlüften denn selbst im
rhein-main-gebiet sinken die
temperaturen bis zum frühen morgen auf
19 grad 12 graz und dessen der oberpfalz
oder auch am alpenrand und wenn sie
dennoch nicht gut schlafen können
schauen sie vielleicht mehr in den
himmel und entdecken eine sternschnuppe
das sind die perseiden auch wenn deren
höhepunkt erst ende nächster woche
erreicht wird auch morgen die sonne
scheint nur kleine quellwolken die
bringen wenig schatten und keinen regen
so wird es heiss bei uns die
temperaturen klettern auf 30 bis 36 grad
und nur der nordsee ist es nicht ganz so
heiß bei 28 29 grad der donnerstag
bringt temperaturen bis 39 grad und dann
kommen kräftige gewitter die die hitze
aus deutschland vertreiben guten abend